الان من مقر انعقاد قمه الايجات في جيبوتي
مراسل الجزيره محمد طه التوكل نرحب بك
محمد اذا جيبوتي حاضنه لقمه ثلاثيه
ستعقوها قمه الايجاد والازمه في السودان
تتصدر عناوين هذه القمتين التفاصيل لديك
طبعا
نعم ازدهار حيث اقف ربما خلال دقائق ربما
قبل ان اكمل هذا اللايف قد يدخل الرؤساء
حسب الموعد الان هي ساعه السفر لانطلاقه
لكن يبدو الجلسه المغلقه
طالت وطال انتظارها التي تدمر رؤساء الدول
الثلاثه جيبوتي جنوب السودان كينيا لقد
استمعوا الرؤساء الى تقرير من مبعوثه
الامين العام المتحده الى القرن الافريقي
وقدمت لهم تصور متكامل وايضا اللجنه
الوساطه استمعوا تقرير من الاتحاد
الافريقي وخارطه الطريق الاليه الموسعه
هذا اللقاءات طبعا هذا الجلسه المغلقه
ومستمره ربما
[موسيقى]
حالما انتهت القمه الثلاثيه حتى تكون هناك
قمه مغلقه للرؤساء الدول الايجاد للبحث عن
اجنده القمه ومنها طبعا انتقل الرئاسه
طبعا كانت لدى السودان منذ عام 2020 نتيجه
ازمه كورونا ونتيجه الاوضاع اخرى في عهد
رئيس الوزراء السابق حمدوك تنازلت عنها
جيبوتي ونقلتها لكن حاليا ايضا هذا قضيه
خلافيه هناك
جنوب السوداني تطلع بان يتولى رئاسه
الايقاد وايضا السودان كنوع من الدعم
السياسي يطالب ان يحتفز برئاسه منظمه
الامور لا زالت مستمره ولكن يتوقع جابوت
التي تنازلت السودان عام
2019 ربما تعود اليها الرئاسه اللقاءات
الجانبيه الكل مؤكد على اهميه انهاء الودع
في السودان وخارج الطريق التي معلوماتها
التي سربت لنا من الجلسه المغلقه هناك
تصور واضح من اللجنه الوساطه سترفعها
للقمه ومن اهمها لا حل عسكري في السودان
وثانيا يعتقدوا ان سبب ازمه السودان هو
التغيير الدستوري الذي حدث في السودان
واستولى المؤسسه العسكريه على السلطه
والنتيجه نتيجه صراع الداير بين المؤسسه
العسكريه فبالتالي هناك الخارطه الطريق
ستتبناها
الايجاد وستكون طبعا ملزمه للاتحاد
الافريقي مبدئيا ازدهار هناك ترحيب بوقف
اطلاق النار وبجهود التي قامت بها
السعوديه وامريكا ولكن الايجاد ترى حل
دائم ونهائي ويجب ان لا يتوقفوا امام
معاناه شعب تكامله يقمع وينزع والقتال
يدور في اكبر عاصمه افريقيه فبالتالي هناك
قلق كبير من انتشار السرعه الى دول الجوار
فبالتالي سنرى ما سيتمخد عن القمه وعن
الجلسه المغلقه سنوافيكم اول اول ازدهار
وسنبقى معك في اطار المتابعه من مقر
انعقاد قمه
مراسل الجزيره محمد طه توكل شكرا جزيلا لك